my name is bill hemmer i started working  at the fox news channel in august of  2005. across the media landscape it  seemed as if everyone was reporting the  same story the same way and fox came  along and took that same story and  flipped it 180 degrees i think that's  what makes us distinct  is what makes us different and it's what  makes people watch us day in and day out  in new york bill hammer fox news when i  first started uh we were doing a  breaking news story i remember being on  the set and my producer was in my ear  saying  hit refresh should i i'm throwing my  hands up in the air f5 on the keyboard  that's refresh we've been hitting that  button ever since it has made us new it  has made us bold and it has made us dare  i say fresh  [Music]  you